There are growing calls for conspiracy theorist
Alex Jones to be arrested for threatening
comments that he made about President elect
Joe Biden over the weekend at the supposedly
in Magga rally in D.C., which fell just just
a little bit short of a million people.
And Alex Jones talked about removing Joe Biden
one way or another.
That was the language he used.
Take a look.
And it's in the midst of this absolutely unhinged
rant.
I understand the video quality is not good
in this clip.
It's actually atrocious.
This is the best we were able to find.
Take a look.
We will never back down to the satanic pedophile
globalist New World Order and their walking
dead reanimated corpse, Joe Biden.
And we will never recognize him.
Trump President Trump has zero connection
to Russians, no proof.
Four years of investigation with the pythons.
It's open and shut.
So I don't know who's going to the White House
in 38 days, but I sure know this.
Joe Biden is a globalist and Joe Biden will
be removed one way or another.
Now, one way or another suggests violence,
it's it alludes to assassination, given that
Joe Biden won and states certified the wins
and the electors voted and that Joe Biden
will be sworn in on January 20th.
And the scariest thing about all of this is
that someone as prominent as Alex Jones ranting
like this is bad enough.
But Alex Jones is doing the rant in front
of exactly the type of crowd that might actually
get some ideas from hearing Alex Jones say
this stuff.
And that really gets into the bulk of the
issue that I want to confront.
We have to confront and I'm not exactly sure
how Alex Jones lawyers have previously said
in court that he's playing a character on
his show.
Now, that's a very common legal defense for
these types.
When they say insane things, they will say
it's a character.
But that video clip I played for you is not
from a show.
It's a political rally.
It's a political event.
And Alex Jones is still saying these things.
But fair enough.
Maybe simply saying it in these terms, we
have to remove Joe Biden one way or another.
Maybe he doesn't mean violence.
Maybe he means impeachment or something.
Maybe it doesn't rise to anything beyond mere
political opinion.
But it's not just that this is a crowd that
might fall for it and do something, thanks
to Alex Jones without diagnosing anyone.
If you watch Alex Jones and think he's a journalist
or someone giving you good information, like
I know people who watch him as mere entertainment,
sort of like shock value or disaster porn,
OK, but if you watch Alex Jones, I think you're
getting information from a journalist and
that maybe that's information that you could
act on.
You probably have some issues yourself.
And I'm not vaguely throwing around the term
mentally ill.
And I know that it would be fraught to do
that.
But I think that we can all understand that
the people most likely to see Alex Jones rants
as a source of news and take them to heart
are people that he is exploiting who have
very real issues of different kinds, let's
put it that way, without diagnosing anything.
And so the question of how far playing a character
goes is a real practical, a serviceable question.
Jones lawyer stated on the record that Jones
is playing a character and is a performance
artist and argued that you can't judge Alex
Jones based on what he says on his show, that
it would be like judging Jack Nicholson when
he played the Joker in Batman, which, by the
way, was the first movie I saw when I moved
to the US back in 1989 1990.
But way more people know when they watch Batman
and they see the Joker, they know it's fiction.
They know these are actors, the people who
would hear Alex Jones and think, OK, he's
sort of a news guy in some way.
They are really doing something that is a
much more precarious, precarious situation.
Batman and Joker are obvious characters.
Alex Jones is acting like a real person who's
acting under his own name.
And that's why the legal argument that his
lawyers made falls apart.
But it doesn't matter because he's still influencing
people's behavior.
I actually believe the better analogy is pro
wrestling, where wrestlers sometimes wrestle
under their real names and are are performing
in a way that's intended to get people to
suspend disbelief.
It sort of looks like real wrestling.
And case in point, if a pro wrestler, whether
in character or not, made a threat to an elected
official, I think the Secret Service would
immediately act on it to see if it's a real
threat.
So this is very, very low and we really have
a perfect storm here.
We have Trump insisting it was rigged on a
Newsmax supporting it and given giving oxygen
to these ideas.
And people like Alex Jones and the my pillow
guy, Michael and Dell and others fueling the
fire.
And it could get very ugly very quickly.